with guardians of the galaxy volume 2 on
the horizon it feels like the perfect
time to remind the world of exactly why
the guardians are so great these
intergalactic superheroes have battled
the forces of evil for almost 50 years
now or at least some incarnation of the
group has anyway if that sounds
confusing then keep watching because
we've got plenty of Guardians trivia
you've probably never heard before
the original Guardians sure star-lord
and Groot are awesome but they're total
newbies to the guardians of the galaxy
the original team was created in 1969 as
a parallel to DC's Legion of
super-heroes the team was based in the
31st century and included very different
members Vance
Astro from Earth Martin X from Pluto
Charlie 27 from Jupiter and finally one
you may almost recognize
yondu from centauri for the foursome
initially joined forces in Marvel
superheroes number 18 to battle an alien
race known as the Badoon the team would
soon grow to take on two additional
members star hawk and Nikki a wild
star-lord appears once upon a time
Marvel published a black and white
magazine called Marvel preview the
experimental title provided creators
with the opportunity to do stories about
characters a bit too far outside the
mainstream
star-lord was one of them first
appearing in 1976 although the character
continued to pop up here and there over
the years it wasn't until the 2004
series Thanos that he officially
returned in this incarnation his
backstory was tweaked and as earlier
adventures were ruled as being outside
Marvel's main continuity but make no
mistake the purists still remembers the
Milano you may have picked up that
star-lord cinematic ship is called the
Milano and no it's not named after the
delicious cookie director James Gunn
tweeted in July of 2014 that the ship is
actually named after actress Alyssa
Milano which falls perfectly in line
with young Peter Quill's 1988 abduction
after all the pubescent quill
disappeared from Earth just as Milano
was the most famous 16 year old on the
planet due to her role in who's the boss
I am Groot it was all the way back in
the 1960s tales to astonish number 13
that group made his debut at the time
the creature of walking would came from
Planet X was much more talkative and was
bent on capturing humanity within a few
pages Groot is defeated by a guy with a
box of termites and it takes decades for
the merciless mahagony to turn up as
anything
than a guest-starring ginkgo fruits
reinvention took place around the same
time of star-lords thanks to marvel's
epic 2004 crossover storyline
annihilation conquest and even though
movie Groot was reduced to a three word
script consisting of you said that voice
actor Vin Diesel read his line over a
thousand times ah well that's just as
fascinating as the first 89 times you
told me that what is wrong with giving
tree during a red carpet interview with
marvel diesel explained when I came into
the recording booth there was a 50 page
document and on the left hand side it
said I am Groot and on the right hand
side it would have a paragraph or a
sentence explaining what he was really
meaning or what he was really trying to
say Drax the real estate agent guardians
of the galaxy is pretty short on origin
stories so trying to explain the history
of Drax the destroyer is a little
complicated in the comics he begins his
existence in 1973 as real-estate agent
Arthur Douglas who is then killed by
Thanos and later resurrected by Thanos
his father for the sole purpose of
killing Thanos after missing his chance
to kill his killer twice Drax decides
that he may as well be a good guy if you
can't beat him and you can't get sweet
revenge on your murderer join him bug
out
bug has been a part of Marvel since 1979
when the company obtained the rights to
produce a micronauts comic based on the
toy line of the same name akroy the
enemy and the micronauts space warriors
also separately bug was originally known
as galactic warrior but because the
comic character looked nothing like the
toy Marvel changes name and made him
their own bug bounced around the Marvel
Universe for years eventually turning up
with the newer Guardians James Gunn was
cites about the idea of using bug but it
didn't work out he broke the bad news on
the podcast the movie crypt there was a
really good chance bug was gonna show up
in the first movie oh really but he is
not we do not own him also just barely
missing from guardians due to right
squabbles fan favorite Ron the space
knight a toy slash comic crossover that
gun also wanted to include but Marvel
just didn't have the rights anymore the
collectors collection there are a lot of
fascinating things to be seen with the
collectors collection many of which are
Easter eggs aimed at hardcore Marvel
fans
these include Cosmo the space
what may or may not be Adam warlocks
cocoon and even Howard the Duck in a nod
to his own film catalog gun also
included some of the alien slugs that
terrorized the town in his 2006 film
slither so wait does that mean that film
is a part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the mind boggles also
originally intended to be part of the
collection Stan Lee himself Gunn didn't
think the first idea for his cameo was
quite up to par however that's a shame
too because the plan had been to show
him as part of the collectors collection
and have him flip off the camera road to
nowhere you may have noticed that the
collector kind of lives in a giant
floating head the film doesn't go into
it much but the head formerly rested on
the shoulders of a celestial according
to marvel's official documentation
Celestials are a star fairing race of
humanoid aliens who possess untold
cosmic power standing 2,000 feet tall
the Celestials are clad in full body
armor no earth being has ever seen what
they look like beneath their armor or
knows their origin something else that
remains unknown is how the head of one
of these things even fell off and ended
up as a port of call at the end of the
universe we don't want to meet the guy
who can decapitate a half mile tall God
new endings gun's original version for
the end of guardians involved Peter
Quill's grandfather played by Greg Henry
in an interview tied to the blu-ray
release of the film he explained that
Henry's moment in particular was just
too much of a downer to keep he had this
photograph of Meredith Peter Quill's
mother and Peter has a little boy and he
looks up at the stars and it was really
sweet it means that he must have seen
claw getting abducted at the end of that
day and is still waiting for him to
return but it was freaking sad so we
took it out star-lord and star man rock
out David Bowie spent much of his career
focusing on space he famously played an
alien in the man who fell to earth and
even once led a band called the spiders
from Mars they're really a freak I don't
mean that unkindly I like pigs so he
would have been a perfect fit for the
guardians galaxy unfortunately Bowie
didn't live long enough to appear in the
sequel like most of us Gunn found out
about Bowie's passing on Twitter and
took to Facebook to express his grief
just a very short while ago Kevin Feige
and I were talking about a cameo role in
guardians volume 2 and he brought up
Bowie's name I told him nothing in the
world would make me happier but I heard
from common friends he wasn't doing well
we heard back that he was okay and it
could potentially happen
who knows what that was about but for
whatever reason it being my Twitter
revelation more of a surprise Oh what
might have been thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know any weird guardians of the galaxy
facts you may know